explained to us please you grew up in
Nigeria what was the age there that you
were my father got in his head to move
us all there when I was three when you
were three yeah so my memory start when
I walked off how interlinked are these
nations can we look at Ivory Coast
Sierra Leone Liberia directly to the
west of Nigeria are they separate and
removed or do you prefer I much more
interlayer their flights that go back
and forth so you've already had an
insensate roads their roads are not
particularly good but there there is you
know people do go back and forth you've
already had one person Liberian goda to
Nigerian died so these borders were
fairly porous they're relatively porous
there's a lot just of going back and
forth within a small distance that the
traffic between the capital cities is
not huge other than planes but it is
porous enough that if you start seeing
the the virus spread you could have a
much more serious epidemic the biggest
impact right now in the economy is the
fear monrovia Freetown are basically
paralyzed nobody's going out in the
streets and so the economy is dropping
right off and if that starts going into
Nigeria or ivory coast you got more
serious plane abidjan which is near
ghana correct I've got there I mean we
trudged on my map here I'm old enough to
remember Upper Volta from what I know
but but with in seriousness Lagos yeah
to rural Nigeria abidjan to the rural
parts what is that linkage to people
from the rural parts it's are they is
removed or are they not it's cut country
by country I mean they're different
infrastructures I mean my friend
McDowell Cooper is moving her kids out
of the orphanage in two different
villages to get them away from the
center if you if you are in Togo you can
get from one place to another because
the roads can sort of function if you go
your your Legos you can't go 20
kilometers in less than four hours but
in terms of the you know the traffic
from the small towns of the big cities
it's not very fast i mean the roads
aren't that developed at in general and
west at how is it then that the disease
can travel so quickly and so readily
when infrastructure is
far backward I well I think there's
obviously the issue of lack of
sanitation which becomes a big problem
but it's it's it's how the virus travels
it's you know through sweat so you can
have people who share bed you know bed
linens that can pass that way any kind
of contact so if you get a concentration
Monrovia Freetown it can pass there but
one of the efforts are trying to do is
contain you know the populations we're
talking earlier about the prospects of
Africa of investing in Africa is
something like this enough to change
that that momentum where does now no I
mean I think you know it's unfortunate
in a way that you get the Africa summit
all the leaders come in and all of a
sudden you get the headlines right no up
until three days ago was with the
distraction of Gaza and the Ukraine in
Argentina now you've got this Ebola
crisis and if you anything with Africa
you don't want to associate with disease
famine and you know pestilence there's a
thriving economy in most of these
countries and and you'd hope that the
fact that you know you have two
presidents who didn't come over doesn't
distract from the building that can go
on and there's a whole other issue of
corruption etc etc but the real story in
Africa is that evolution and the
emergence of the middle class whether
it's the World Health Organization or
others Charles calamares let me address
us to you when we look at our
well-meaning well spirited institutions
helping Africa either medically with
bacterial or viral issues or
institutions helping like the World Bank
are they still getting in the way of
each other is you know you and I have
studied about nasa and aswan dam zup
another time and place yes and largely
failing by the way build easterlies new
book tyranny of experts really documents
this and explains it very well it's not
necessarily an evil plan it's just that
top-down sort of planning doesn't really
work very well and intergovernmental
sort of deal-making is often not very
affecting you give the World Bank high
grades for their shift is mr. dr. Kim
rather [ __ ] I am now oh come on be nice
it's 1 i'm sorry i think that the World
Bank's leadership their main
accomplishments every four years is to
restructure the world bank staff
I you know I have to say on the debt
problems for Africa the World Bank was
absolutely instrumental in resolving and
they the Booker sapphic that was ten
years ago that you're talking yeah okay
but well and you also commented your
best return since founding your firm in
1997 have come from Africa could you not
have done that with the help of the
World Bank you know I think that the
it's complicated they were instrumental
in in structuring the way that things
worked out ultimately we may have gotten
more out of some of the restructurings
have been more painful I think the world
bank staff was actually very helpful in
resolving the issues okay thumbs up for
the World Bank from Hans Humes